because you can't talk him out of it he
Lexi's read for like five minutes and
you can't turn it off is that from your
dad yeah my dad was a rageaholic
it was a rageful man you are not you had
your mom
irate easily and annoyed but you don't
have that real like volcanic eruption
because I have I have I don't know I
think I do have it I just have this
ability because I know what my dad is
like where it's like I just kind of go
just you know III just was able to deal
with it better you know like if I feel
like coming up I just have other tools
that I use in my mind to believe it or
whatever but my brother doesn't have it
also my brother um I'm not I don't have
never trusted my own physical strength
and my fighting abilities but my brother
has like my brother knows that he can
Russell my my brother can take people
down like he could take you down if you
wanted to yeah he's very strong and it's
fast yeah but I've never had confidence
in my own physical abilities so I
already know I have to result or to
resort to other ways to survive I went
down an alleyway on Sunset once because
my manager Abdul was at a bar and some
weird bar and I walked through this
alleyway and this big black guy came up
to me and I realized he had no pants on
it his dick out he goes tell me what a
socket right and instead of in his face
right are you always caught in the it's
in instead of like getting in his face
like my brother would like what what
[ __ ] I ran I like you it didn't
even once he said it I was gone yeah
like I could just get out which is
basically the correct that is the
correct thing to do you know it's very
um Theon Greyjoy I jump over the ship I
jump over the ship when like you know
when I say when I see danger on our
that's taking the path of least
resistance why wouldn't you if I were in
that same situation I would remove
myself from it I wouldn't confront the
person
would yet is what they teach yeah but
it's like the Thai ki was on the Titanic
I feel like I'd be alive but I'd be
floating on like 50 passengers backs
passengers I would like to survive so
your honor you're on a board floating if
you see like Leo basically and he say
let me get the board with you no I know
I would make him a part of my board
survive we make a human life raft yeah
yeah and sit and float on their backs
but so you're you don't know then if you
are being cowardly or if you are
forceful a survival like if you're being
it could be a divider violet I'm a
survivalist I've been a survivalist
survivor know I know I'm a survivalist
survivalists are those people that live
on naked I know and I can do I do that
as well
I listen you you doubt me you know what
you know what baby you know I doubt for
those who've you dumped for those of you
doubt me I'll drink [ __ ] hyena pee no
it's not that I don't like lemonade on
that [ __ ] I don't doubt your ability and
your your I think you're game for it I
don't I doubt your blood sugar I doubt
that you'd actually be physically able
to withstand going ten hours without a
meal okay the way you treat me when
you're hungry yeah I'll tell you this
I'll tell you this right now uh-uh I
will do a survival game show with you
three will see it I will come on top on
top okay so give give us a scenario
where are we on a beach what do we have
to hunt for let's go let's go legit
let's go to the Congo I'll be a part of
the monkey Drive in like two weeks if
there is if it's by an ocean I'll win
for sure no that's your thing that's
your thing that's my thing that's my
yeah so no we're not we're going not
we're going to go inland okay the bus I
can do everything yeah
the one thing I cannot do is like super
arid or like really really dry condition
let's go I do great dry stuff really oh
yeah you're the kind of guy George and I
know this for a fact that you know that
movie alive yeah I love that he be he be
the guy eating
every one but like but like not as soon
as we crashed not reluctantly like will
yeah when he doesn't even need to kill
us yet like he will just start eating us
yeah just logical he just very large
staying ahead Jesus Christ you would
drink around pee right oh yeah but it
would be unnecessary that's not what
Bear Grylls said yeah but you can only
drink your pee for so long like it
there's like a limit to how much of your
own pee you can actually drink
but is there hydrating qualities to it
tell me how you would make a well how a
[ __ ] hole actually is one that is step
one that is step one right yeah but you
would try to make it sort of like here's
what I would do there's a river okay
there's a river is a river what I'll do
is I'll go next to the river that's I
would dig a hole I'd have the river
filter filter into my hole and that uses
as a thing filter for thing and I'll
sprinkle tration water and if not you
know what I'll do I'll make a little
bamboo cups right and when it rains I'll
capture all the rain in these bamboo
clubs but I've developed what do you do
with your body if it's getting bit up by
insects and mosquitoes that can help I
don't know what to do but you know what
they'll die because of the things I have
inside my body
the mosquitoes started spreading I'm
starting my own disease ooh burn like a
termite mound or like hover your body
smoke yeah and smoke so good I don't
know I'd do a fire that's the most
difficult but you can immunity situation
no one would know that you're if you're
covered in mud or not just it's a skin
color I'm sorry it's true that is very
good
[Music]